j'ai peur t'inquiète pas c'est la
première fois que ton nom fait partie
d'un tirage au sort et maintenant que le
rassemblement camors
béthune hier shot
ouais je bent est choisi fini les jeux
pour moi à aa
maintenant il va falloir compter choisi
saillard soit accompagnée
mais la luz et at il une belle année 6
in cui c'est la meilleure grande soeur
au monde regarde ce que j'ai tant que tu
le rassure toi rien de mal ne pourrait
arriver
[Musique]
75e jeu de la tête une personne
importante dans ta vie oui il ya une
personne c'est marco tu es une vraie
merde j'ai tout mon pied au cul ça doit
être très douloureux 4 3
bien joué je vais mourir c'est ça non ça
peut plus durer
de quoi besoin une émission qui marche
pour avoir encore plus de succès d'une
usine entre lesbiennes qui n'aiment pas
voir deux filles ensemble au lit
qu'attend-t-on qui tue tout on va faire
l'amour entre ma vie
ok mais juste une pointe et c'est si bon
et c'est encore mieux en 3d
[Musique]
on n'a qu'à les tuer ipic m
qu'est ce que vous faites ici
j'apparais à la fin de pratiquement tous
les films abidjan a semblé fait
attention mettez pas la bise
[Musique]